that's living to see you here Christian
earn at lf-cc how you enjoying it so far
it has been extremely intense has been
much crazier than last year
Jesus Christ yeah I don't expect it to
be so busy so it's been a great day now
of course you've been really enjoying
coders season four it's been very
exciting
now how fun is it playing morgue door as
I like to call it the brand it's my
favorite actually it's out of all the
things I've done and all the seasons
it's definitely my favorite my favorite
aspect of Hodor I like to end up that's
ideas personnel well not not heads
personality but yeah it's definitely a
lot of fun it's been on the rampage
doesn't hear me you guys lock and then
there was all the whites and you were
putting your fingers in their eyes
sockets and pulling them all over the
place was that like yeah white bullying
my favorite was definitely the lock
saying though I loves I love to hoisted
him up by the neck and stuff obviously
it wasn't real but unfortunately yeah
that felt quite empowering so I'm trying
to find someone with a really strong
neck so contrite for real not a good
idea behind the scenes that how did it
work it was like a pulley I got a hoist
so a little bit of pressure on the neck
and even fly it up yeah yeah you felt
like if you had super strength
yeah so that was me as Superman for the
day yeah yeah I want that and of course
the season 4 finale was just incredible
wasn't it for the brand clan
very complex in the film to be honest
there's a lot of special effects
yeah almost a whole week actually to do
that scene how's it work and be you guys
on set well they have a lot of green
screen they had a lot of stuntmen and
their address and weights outfits yeah
they've got all of also bets missing and
stuff and green screen in the background
yeah I mean it was very technically
advanced I think um the visual effects
Department had did more than ever have
before in Game of Thrones for that scene
but yeah but you know I was with always
that some of it was real so the quarry
was real that the best of the trade was
real so you can sort of Mars yeah I mean
it was incredible incredible incredible
self I mean George and of course we lost
him in that scene and we'd shop the book
readers and number rate is alike yeah
yeah I mean that's another one of our
little tail go on the suicide I mean we
all love Thomas but you know what schema
throw this what he expect you know don't
get attached to anybody do you think
when you saw that scene with him Harry
died on in the end I got misty eyed
honestly I got quite sad Ellie's Edna me
isn't job and I've seen yeah it's very
sad as soon as the word rallying we're
driving
the red reading we're now calling it
yeah the red wedding not only do we see
a Christine or the characters that we
see actors released in part of our
little family so there's another one
can't afford to lose any more from your
little team anymore no no that's just me
Elian Brown oh yeah I'm tree so ya need
to recruit some more do you think the
future is for those or now that brans
what gonna fly worm farming Ali and I
are gonna set up a worm farm or maybe
organic organic vegetables I don't know
okay those or we'll start like I don't
know I have thought about that but
obviously it's not in the books yet so
we'll say I'm sure will not be just left
idle yeah I hope things to do including
taking the crown as y'all soon yeah
hopefully I've got my eye on that yeah
and what did you make you mention the
tree and of course oh it's got the
three-eyed Raven as well there what do
you make of that whole thing with her I
think it's my favorite part of the
storyline I can't wait to see how it
develops I think it's still a mystery
really no one really knows what so hard
to filter night or really what he means
by your fly and stuff but obviously you
can working to be a bird
you can fly anyway so it obviously means
something different but I don't know
what it is I can't we have to find out
now but that whole mysticism aspect yeah
it's definitely my favorite part of the
storyline of course we've lost George
and we lost loads of people as always
the season it with some Biggie's as well
Joffrey well what did you think when you
saw that was great well it's not
surprise to me but I thought the season
was really well done I mean you really
built it up I really wanted to punch him
in the face just before he died yeah
that's they were good at building up so
yeah I think it's a major character gone
though I mean I don't think it's gonna
be the same with item you love to hear
them
you know and then there's Timon gone and
also there's a hound as well but we
don't really know about that
off-screen keeps us guessing who knows
who knows what Game of Thrones
I mean you mentioned zone tyrant as well
of course he went out on the lewd and
they would she make up that would
signify hi under the fight that's the
only way the Tywin could go you know
such an amazing character yet again gone
on the toilet I just love this show
where else do you get this we didn't
mention over Motel he got the shop as
well he came in anyone I mean that was
an incredible bath of what do you think
when you were watching the mountain
versus my phone screen is kind of gross
what a character liked it in a game of
Thrones is famous for that though
introduced an amazing character you fell
in love with them and then goodbye sharp
oh yeah if you could have anything at
all happen for Hodor going forward if
you could like say to Dan and David
listen this is what's gonna happen
George you know this is where we're
going well all I want is all I want is
to find out where he comes from to find
out who he really is and yeah just to
get them a little bit more just to it's
clear himself yeah it's just identity
identity here from where I am today and
find out who he really is and why he is
the way is I think we all won tonight
don't we what there is behind how it's
been ministry and what had been your
highlights of season four I like to bet
in Craster's keep
we're brown wars in - Hodor there I mean
you got to see the process for the first
time properly
sericea its motor functions he has
issues yeah definitely forever
and finally what do you think fans had
find the most surprising thing about
life behind the scenes shooting Game of
Thrones
that's a good question but obviously
everyone always thinks that life is
glamorous on set but really is really a
the personal smelling costumes and
sweating a lot and yeah that's one of
its not promised at all but it makes it
real
it makes it real questions I've been
watching for like four years I think
that's fair miss Knight absolutely rank
rank is the word they have to bleach my
skin every time I get it you have to get
read that when you go back yeah I mean I
usually like a bottle of after she Evans
or spray it all over it yeah that's
awful
so naked flames if you don't say
anything to fans out there who are
watching what you like spacing it don't
do trust
yeah stance cool just keep watching the
show we're all really grateful you know
yeah I think season 5 is gonna be
awesome
we all can't wait to get back to
you